today we're going to create an avatar
that looks and moves like me We Begin by
smiling into the
camera I love to smile smiling is my
favorite and breathing gently for a
short second is this what breathing
looks
like I'm Joanna Stern no I am the real
Joanna okay so I clone myself kind of
Howdy why well the latest AI tools that
generate Tech and images already make it
hard to tell the difference between
what's real and what's fake what's
coming next with AI generated voice and
video is going to blur the lines even
more it's Joanna Stern your iOS wizard
today we're unearthing the Hidden World
of back tap gestures love that I did not
have to shoot
this